there is a new push to make sure that
every eligible ballot is counted in 2020
it's led by Stacey Abrams a 2018
Democratic candidate for governor of
Georgia
she lost her Republican Brian Kemp by
less than two percent of the vote Abrams
says that voter suppression led to her
defeat the election was marred by
widespread reports of irregularities her
new organization bear fight 2020 is
working to ensure that all voters have
access to the polls the organization is
bringing awareness and advocating for
election reform at all levels it's
engaging in targeted voter registration
and other voter outreach programs and
we're glad to say that Stacey Abrams
joins us at the table this morning
Stacey always good to see you thank you
for having so voter suppression would
seem very personal to you but when you
look at what voters are interested in
concerned about it's not on their list
of top three top five top ten what is it
that you want people to know how can we
how can we make people understand why
this is so important
voter suppression is the baseline that
determines whether your voice is heard
whether the values and the policies that
you want ever come to fruition we have
to recognize that voter suppression is
no longer the images from the 1960s or
the laws of the 1960s that forbade
voting for African Americans or the
denial to Native Americans of
citizenship until 1924 what we're
talking about is whether you can
register and stay on the rolls whether
you can cast your ballot and whether
your ballot is counted and we have to
think about that entire spectrum because
over the last 20 years we have seen
numerous laws probably propagated that
have eroded your ability to do those
things especially if you're in a
marginalized community a community of
color or from a community that is seen
as less valuable to the Republican Party
because it's no longer hoses it is no
longer hoses in the streets it's much
more insidious these laws look racially
and facially neutral meaning if you just
talk about them in public everyone
thinks oh that's a great idea then you
realize that for example in North Dakota
they passed a law saying you have to
have a residential address on your
driver's license most Native Americans
do not have residential addresses
because they live on reservations
therefore they disenfranchise thousands
of Native Americans we have to think
about not only what the law says but
what the law does and that's what we're
trying to tackle what do you say to
people who say
voter ID laws or exact match policies
are essentially protecting ya the
election process first of all that our
fraud is a myth it does not exist people
aren't putting on you know fake
mustaches trying to vote twice but voter
suppression is real
we know that voter ID laws seem of
perfectly normal but if you lived in
Alabama when they passed their voter ID
law they also shut down 2/3 I believe of
the organization's of the DMV's in black
community so that the very people who
needed those IDs would not be able to
get them if you live in Indiana where
they move your polling place in Hamilton
County outside of the bounds of the city
if you didn't have a car you couldn't
get to vote and so we have to recognize
is that again these thing these laws
seem very basic but the application and
the implication is that your vote
doesn't matter
and that's why fair fight 2020 org is
designed to go beyond registration we
focus on voter protection getting you on
the rolls making sure you can stay on
the rolls and making sure your ballot
can be cast and counted in discussing
these issues you've said that elections
are in effect rigged which is a word
that President Trump has also used and I
see you nodding there in using a word
like rigs I have to ask it's a it's a
frightening word and I wonder does it
contribute to a possible scenario where
people on either side of an election
outcome don't accept the results there's
a lot that's been made of the fact that
I did not concede my election but I
never denied the legal sufficiency of
that election and that's the difference
between me and Trump he refuses to
acknowledge the legal sufficiency or
threatens not to but my point is that
the laws are wrong we have to fix those
laws because as long as we have eligible
American citizens who cannot cast a
ballot then the game is rigged because
in a democracy you should be allowed to
make your voice heard and as long as
there are rules that prevent that from
happening
rules that should not exist that's a
problem for America you mentioned not
conceding the chair of the RNC rona
McDaniel your smile cuz I'm sure you've
heard that hat yesterday if Stacey
Abrams actually cared about integrity of
Elections
she'd concede the Georgia governor's
race that she lost by 55,000 votes
instead she's on national TV today still
thinking she's won why haven't you
conceded because concession means to say
that the process was fair but when I run
an organization that in ten days
between election night and the night I
refused to concede we received more than
fifty thousand phone calls of people who
were denied the right to vote
I am complicit if I say that that system
is fair I did not deny the legal
sufficiency of the election I am NOT
claiming to be the governor of d'Or -
despite what Breitbart and others like
to say yeah but I have said is that we
won the battle of making sure more
voices were heard because we had the
highest record turnout in Georgia
history for Democrats but and your
opponent was in charge of that my
opponent was in charge of the process
yeah but the other thing to remember is
look because there are more people in
the water that doesn't mean there are
fewer sharks okay you can have higher
turnout but that doesn't diminish the
fact that voter suppression is real and
affecting people across the country
you're not running for president you
mean it but you would consider a vice
presidential candidacy I would be
honored to be considered anybody reached
out to you no one has had this
conversation I've I've talked to them
about making certain that we fight voter
suppression and that Georgia is a
battleground state and those are two
critical pieces for me because Georgia
has the highest percentage of
african-american voters in a
battleground state and we can help take
the presidency and that's why we're in
the twenty battleground states across
this country that you're looking at and
would you would you run with any of them
yeah I would be honored to be considered
for the vice presidency by the nominee
but it is presumptuous for me to think
that they're looking at me what I want
everyone to look at is voter suppression
and that's why during the primary while
our candidates are running for president
I'm gonna be running to make certain
that we are putting voter protection
teams in our twenty battleground states
and we're ready for the newsroom's thank
you very much for being with us this
morning thank you